hi everyone welcome to another episode
in wolfram language design our
incremental language design
meeting we have a variety of topics for
today first one is general operator
forms
i don't exactly know what this means so
this was partially inspired by a
discussion um that we had with our nude
and a handful of other people about
he had proposed this function called
random selection which is basically an
operator form of random sample because
the one arg form is already taken and
in looking through function repository
submissions and other things people have
proposed there's a whole class of things
that are basically operator forms of
existing functions that can't work
within the existing design of those
functions because
whatever the operator form would be has
already been um what's wrong with
operator applied so operator applied is
obviously the the first option you know
that operator applied works for any of
these
some of them are very popular so we
looked at um the second item on there we
looked at a couple of weeks ago same as
q which we've talked about using
uh the greenlit version of that is same
as
i think there
is a discussion to be had about you know
what the threshold is of something
that's useful to have a dedicated
operator form or to have a natural
language or
a system implemented version of the
operator
i think operator applied works for
things that are relatively
straightforward but things like set two
we don't really i mean i guess you could
use operator applied
for that what is tattoo uh so it's the
third item on the list there it's
basically the operator version of set
so
this list of six functions here all
relatively popular on the function
repository they're all ones that we
would consider looking at but the
question is do we just want to say ah
these are all things that could be done
in operator applied and so they're not
worth looking at well they could be done
as x equals blah x equals ampersand yeah
right you could obviously make a pure
function version of each of these
that's interesting
um
yeah
each of these has interesting use cases
and most of them are stymied from
the terse is just a operator form of
short
for a number of lines
a lot of them get a little cheeky
because they're trying to use a synonym
for the existing function and i don't
like having two functions with synonyms
just because we want an operator version
we already have a big problem with
random choice versus sample
right so that makes it even worse if we
try to add operator forms for one or
both and change the naming
okay so one possible approach would be
that there is a
a
a modification to names
that is routine that means it's the
operator form of that function
right yeah so we have like append and
append two which isn't quite operator
form but that's the mutable version
equal equal to
same at yeah so that's kind of the the
last point i had in the agenda on this
subject was do we want to have a general
naming paradigm that makes these
operator forms sensible
do we we've been doing it on kind of a
case-by-case basis and since it's come
up relatively frequently frequently
especially in wfr functions i wanted to
have a general
roadmap for how we look at that
obviously
not very popular things or one-off
things operator applied or current
applied or curry applied would be the
way to go
okay so so which ones here are seriously
common i mean
um something important here
sorry something important here is that
operator applied cannot handle
attributes or holding attributes
something like set to
need probably needs
to have its own operator
um by the way we've got a bunch of
background noise from daniel
yeah sorry
um
okay
uh actually how do the operator how do
attributes work with resource functions
though because aren't resource functions
also some kind of sub value internally
that's a good point i don't know does
somebody know here
ian danny
no i was i was going to ask do they work
the same way as pure not off i don't
know hand
do they work period
i thought they were rigged to work
operative term being rigged
i think that they may work by being
by the head evaluates to a
contexturified function which then can
have attributes
like that
sounds plausible well actually i'm
looking i mean it's a
i'm not sure like i'm just looking at
the full form and and
yeah it doesn't look like it evaluates
so i i don't know how it works but it
does appear to work
okay
well so then the question is could
operator applied
have like function
um could we cut the background noise
okay
um
uh could operator replied like function
take attributes
in itself
to
be able to deal with that
well maybe the thing to do i mean
maybe it would make sense to have it
inherit the attributes but it would have
to inherit them in some pretty bizarre
way
okay who knows about operator applied
here
i i do i wrote that function
okay i was thinking about it so because
operator applied is supposed to work
with any combination of brackets i find
it difficult
so because it has to carry so if it's a
function with
seven arguments
having a hold attribute on the rest
could be complicated
let's at least have a think about it but
okay but let's take a look at these ones
here
um
how many
serious operator forms
are there i mean in other words
the um
uh
do you mean special symbols that are
only operator forms or do you mean
operator forms period no i
well
no well i'm sorry i asked the question
badly what i'm asking is
functions that we might imagine should
have an operative form i mean i'm not
convinced about this one this terse one
that seems
somewhat obscure
yeah that's probably the most obscure of
them okay what is same as
so same as is an operator form of same q
we looked at that one
last week or the week before and said
that probably makes sense we weren't
sure about the
inverse version of unsame as or unsame
we started looking at i started looking
at an implementation of it and wanted to
make sure we had the name right and that
if we were looking at other things like
this
that we're using a
common design for the operators well i
think what we've got here is a
preposition you know equal to same as if
basically the
the construct is thing preposition that
might give us enough freedom might give
us enough uniformity to be able to for
people to know what's going on but
enough freedom that we're not going to
get stupid names
except that we already do have things
like append 2 and associate 2 and stuff
like that
yeah which which already confused me
with this equal to thing
right
yeah i mean also there are some
questions like for example the same as q
arguably i mean the issue is we have two
different they're two different suffixes
so arguably should actually be same q as
except i think having the q in the
middle looks really ugly
right which is why we talked about just
dropping the q
but it's
what is equal to
equal to is an operator form of equal
correct but it is frustrating that
append to
is a mutable form of append
right where append also has an operator
form but it's just called append
right
um
i would kind of argue that
yeah i i think given that we have
operator applied it seems like we should
kind of have a relatively high bar for
when things should get their own
operator form symbol because because
otherwise it's sort of like
you know for every for every argument of
every symbol we can have an operator
form
okay here's a question
the which uh andrew on our live stream
is commenting on this
um
okay so
who's basically suggesting an infix form
of operator applied
so let's consider that possibility
because i mean if we did have something
like that
how would that work
is this fix for inside of a composition
or what
well i i suppose but but um
uh the issue is that we need both a
postfix and a prefix form of it
because what we want
what if you're mapping this operator
form what if i'm mapping
same as q
of two over a big list
um
right how would that work i mean in
other words
okay
i mean probably it is too obscure
to imagine
some kind of tight binding operator form
okay so let's imagine that we could do
this
let's imagine that we had a um
uh you know some
some weird notation
which i'm not thrilled that it's a weird
notation but let's imagine it was a
weird notation you know xsclam at sine
whatever
that means
that is the equivalent to operator
applied
of same cue
well now we have to have a curry form
right here
i'm not mistaken it also reveals how how
much i have not used operator applied in
a serious way
um
yeah
so this would be i mean in the case of
your short example up above this would
be
you know something like this
which then would become
you know in other words if there was a
short form of operator applied
is that is there any serious possibility
of that
comments
everybody's on mute because i've been
complaining about noise
um
this has been suggested i'm i'm looking
for a suggestion that i'm going to put
in the chat
so this is a bullet notation
and then you can it's a bit like hash
but without the need of the
of the ampersand and and this is
implemented with curry
wow
that's a bit wild
it's kind of amazing that that works but
but at the same time
i mean
couldn't you just write hash and then an
ampersand at the end pretty much
yeah i mean the steps are possible for
some precedence issues but it's not
clear why this
i mean it has a certain clarity to it
but then so is the hash thing
i i think it's the other has to be
sorry go ahead
i'm sorry um these was created to
simplify
uh the query language of the dataset
so it doesn't involve ampersands also
or is it a precedence issue
i think it's just to avoid the use of
ampersand so it feels closer to
operative forms
so another detail or another difference
with it in hash is that you can't use
the bullet more than one level deep is
that right
i think so
boy that's interesting i mean you know
pure functions are a very common
construct and having yet another
notation for them doesn't seem
completely crazy
it's confusing though i mean in
see this is
i mean i wonder if there could be a name
here for this
uh
you know because i think it would be a
little less
i mean this is getting into the
distinctly obscure category
and another thing that is some exotic
character here is going to be hard to
type
um
if we named the thing that went here
uh
what the heck could be it it's got to be
some preposition like
thing
i mean i'm just going to type a word
which isn't a very good word
if we had a word like that
um
i'm thinking of
sort of this is the
this is a very bad word as well but
that's kind of the idea
so
what
so is this
is this supposed to solve the problem
operator forms or is this doing
something else
it's supposed to solve the problem of
operative forms it's something that is
lightweight enough
that instead of having a member queue
width or something
operator form well member queue only has
an operator form that's useful
oh my gosh this is to deal with that you
can have exactly one bullet so that's
like omitting one argument whereas
operator
forums are usually like
giving one of the arguments and the
others can be filled
which i guess is not different in the
case of like
exactly two arguments
right
well but i mean this is
so
go ahead
sorry i think this is a way of having a
simpler notation for career applied in
the most frequent case but it's far from
the power that carry applied or operator
has
yes of course
we actually see just out of curiosity if
you run it without the
of a like you just run member queue of
abc
bullet
what does that evaluate to
um
okay
what is all these ones doing what
happens if i had more than six what what
is that what is that
doing wait what where did you evaluate a
list of ones
i think you have c defined it's in black
oh my god
oh maybe c is that is that list of ones
yeah yeah that's that's apparently it
does
okay
i wonder i mean syntactically i don't
know how this would work but i wonder
something like hash dot
it's very obscure
i mean this is basically just an
automatic way of putting the ampersand
one level higher than the hash
yes that's correct
right is this because query looks at the
head of the expression so having it be a
pure function
interferes with that oh that's if that's
true it's just crazy no you can have
pure functions just the the the order in
which it
pure functions are always descending or
something yeah
but that's just because of some hackery
and query which should be fixed
that's that's not a real thing that's
because of hackery there the real
question is is it a syntactic
convenience
you know for example i routinely use
this form of function occasionally
you know occasionally that's super nice
and super useful
and you know it's such a common
construct i do wonder whether having
this form where there's a single
argument
that you can
you know if we could get a nice version
of this
it might be a good thing to have
well maybe another question is does this
solve a precedence problem because well
i mean really it seems like
it's it's it's the same character count
if you're writing hash dot it's the same
character count as putting an ampersand
at the end right the only benefit would
be if it fixes a precedence thing it
does it fixes the precedence on the
right-hand side of an arrow
you could routinely put a one-argument
function on the right-hand side of an
arrow without any problem with the
ampersand
on the other hand it would be so
confusing because you wouldn't well i
guess you would know that the hash dot
doesn't go with the arrow because the
arrow but what if you have a hash dot
inside of an ampersand as a pure
function returning another pure function
that would be super confusing
well this is the same issue as with
pronouns in english
i mean the hash is a pronoun basically
and with pronouns in english
and
you know and and even you know number
and gender agreement is now no longer
and so you know that that halves the
number of pronouns i mean in other words
pronouns are a hack where you have to
have
uh
you know
the cat chased the mouse and it ran fast
you're out of luck there
they just do like in in latin right they
have they have um they have two they
have like you know hawk and illa or
whatever it's just you can arbitrarily
kind of pick
you know so you can have two two generic
pronouns running around but i feel like
how do they how does how does latin
decide which which one it refers to well
i think one of them kind of means this
and one of them kind of means that and
there's a third one that is something
slightly weirder but but like they they
they kind of just in in actual sentences
they'll often like one person or thing
will be assigned to this and another
personal thing will be assigned to that
how do you know which one is assigned to
which
um
i don't remember
i think it's just that they they
i think it's just that they'll they'll
i don't know it's from some weird
context
well i mean there are many in natural
language there are you know big red dog
red
red
big dog you know that they're they're
all these weird conventions which seem
natural to people
um but i mean i'm thinking that this is
a little bit similar to that where it's
it's you know we already have one
pronoun for the you know the hash and
we're adding another pronoun
but i feel like it's sort of
you know
basically just adding a totally separate
independent mechanism for having pure
functions
you know just so you can have two
mechanisms so they can interact with
each other seems kind of bizarre
well i mean we have mechanisms like like
this mechanism here is equivalent by the
way um crystal i'm pretty sure you are
the cause of all sorts of weird
elephant-like background noise
i guess my floor is squeaky as i pace
around but yeah okay
the um
the uh
um anyway
the
the um
but so we have this and we have this and
those are obviously equivalent
and you know look it is clear that from
the point of view of writing code simply
having a pronoun that you can stick in
here that means a single hash is clearly
worthwhile
what is that not just single hash
well except then you have to have an
ampersand and then as we point out this
precedence issues right but i mean it's
just i don't know i i'm just
i just think it seems like
introducing another
another totally parallel and pretty much
totally equivalent mechanism for having
pure functions
but that's like totally separate and
different
just so that oh that seems crazy having
two levels of pure function seems kind
of crazy
except that languages have a whole
collection of hacks
for dealing i mean like like look there
are plenty of languages english not
being one where
nouns are randomly assigned genders
thereby
doubling the number of pronoun reference
that you can have
randomly it's just a total heuristic
like anybody speaking language i don't
know
um we definitely got spanish speakers
here is there is there a
how does it work there is it i don't
know whether it has
um
do you mean whether pronouns uh follow a
gender
well no i the question is in english
you know we've got he she in it
okay
but most things in the world other than
people
uh
and
you know
you know with a few minor exceptions
every thing out in the world is an it
but in french for example
there are it's a random assignment of
some things that are are you know
some things can be referred to by
a
masculine pronoun some by a feminine
pronoun
and same in latin
right same in spanish yes we have to
both
know randomly every single noun whether
it's feminine or masculine right but you
see what that's doing
is that just doubled that meant that the
hash sign so to speak that there are two
different
hash sign things that are pulling out
you know
reference in sentences
you know in other words by having two
genders
you are random you are doubling your
statistically you are doubling you're
halving the number of times that you
have to go beyond a pronoun
you just mean if you have a sentence you
know with two objects in it there's a
decent chance that one of them will be
masculine and one of them will be
feminine and you can use pronouns right
so you know
the cat chased the mouse and it ran fast
in english we're toast there we've only
got one pronoun to refer to but if we
said
the cat uh you know i don't know let's
say the cat was called james or
something and it was a masculine cat
then as soon as we say the cat round you
know james the cat ran fast chasing the
mouse
no i'm sorry james the cat chased the
mouse and and
he ran fast
we we know how that reference works
if i'm making sense and there's a direct
analogy here because we need to be able
to refer to
you know we've got
how does this exactly work
we have
right so our pure function
is like a verb
how does this work
yes it ran fast
is like a pure function ran is like the
function and the it
is like the hash
which is grabbing an argument of that
that makes sense
and the issue is which is a little bit
different but slightly but related to
this is
well i mean in that case gosh we we've
got
oh my you see
maybe we could have something
a similar thing would be if you could
have um
i mean this syntax doesn't work but you
could have something where
instead of writing just ampersand you
could write ampersand two
and that will assign hash two and then
if you write ampersand three that'll
assign hash three
and then that way you know you can sort
of have nested ones and and you specify
when you write the ampersand
whether you're binding to this or that
and then you know and that doesn't
actually work but
well okay so a different method
yes it is
it is like the brain indices
i mean
so for example we could imagine
something where
this
um
uh
um
i'm sorry the uh
i was thinking of something where
um
i don't quite know how this works but
the thing being grabbed
somehow is indicated
um
you know
it's kind of like an e you need to
differentiate the ampersands as well
right yes yes you do
so i'm not sure it's helpful and we've
kind of moved on but i was going to
mention uh in terms of linguistic ways
of handling
pronouns japanese is kind of interesting
because there effectively are no
pronouns all pronoun references are used
like they're literally the same as nouns
so if you were saying the cat went over
there it ate its food
the literal way you'd say it is the cat
went over there cat aged food
like you repeat the noun there's nouns
you can reference yourself or to
reference someone who
is masculine or feminine but you also
typically
in conversation will reference someone
even if you're talking to them by their
name
i see
so there's effectively an infinite
pronoun space because you can use any
noun
as a pronoun and there's no special
pronouns
but the assumption there is that if cat
is repeated in the sentence it means the
same cat
that was referred to as the subject in
the sentence
yeah
what about if the noun is long like if
you say something like
the guy in the red shirt
you know
did this then would you later say like
uh the guy
or
he
yeah but if it's the guy in the red
shirt and the guy in the blue shirt
the guy in the red shirt
you know
outran the guy in the red shirt but
whatever blue shirt whatever it is how
would you then back reference those
things
uh
so
i mean it depends on level of formality
and conversation but you could
contextually just reference red shirts
or i say
right person or blue church person in
more formal
speech i'm not a hundred percent sure
okay okay i understand so that that's um
uh
okay so you bake up a temporary now
basically a temporary
um
okay
look it it could very that's also known
as that's also known as
function with with the the arrow where
you pick a name basically arguments
right
i mean the issue is a pronoun is a
nameless noun basically
um
and
okay
you know it could be that our precedence
problem with ampersands will be largely
fixed by this user assistance stuff
that's coming in
with auto auto paren indications
um
but let's come back to our original
question the original question was
do we want
a bunch of new operator forms for these
various functions whether operator forms
are popular or do we want to find a
better general solution to this
and
one general solution would be
a decorator for functions so operator
applied is a decorator for functions
but it is very long and you know one
possibility is a syntactic form for
operator applied
which might be too obscure
uh
that's okay so what are our
possibilities
so one is
syntactic what one is you know okay so
these are our
possibilities
so one is
new operator
operator form functions
for popular cases
another is
a
more succinct
version for more succinct input for
operator applied
another possibility is
new uh
new syntax
for
single hash
dot dot ampersand
i do think that that last one would be
quite interesting
if we could do it without it being just
utterly
you know if we could do it without
people be getting utterly confused
because for example it wouldn't work
presumably and it depends very much on
the name if you said something like this
or that you know whatever a hash dot is
that wouldn't work would it or would it
work or would it lexically scan
well
the bulletproof implemented via value so
well i understand the bullet is but
right and it can't really lexically scan
because it doesn't know how far out to
go
right like imagine putting at the end of
that right open bracket x close bracket
and at the end of the member queue right
open bracket y close bracket which one
is the one you're using that's why you
need to write an
ampersand right so the only way it can
work
um
new syntax for single blah
single single
for single level
uh
argument insertion
but as you say i think it's often like
in that member queue example i think
would be very intuitive to write what
you just wrote
not realizing that it's actually a level
deeper
right but for example we have not had a
lot of confusion with nothing
i mean people know that nothing
is only at that top level of a list
so my question is
could there be something which says uh
you know
you know let's say abc
you know phil here bad name but is there
some name that we can imagine for that
that would make it fairly obvious that
it's a top level only
well there's some
slightly crazy ideas like there's always
the no argument slot
that's crazy
because too close to things that will be
used
i agree no argument started something we
certainly haven't used
but i think that's crazy
um
i mean or worse than that even
the even more crazy
uh
a naked slot
i think it's crazy
because what we want to indicate is that
it will be filled
into here
i don't think we could do it but i was
thinking of the placeholder
yes the placeholder is a nice thing
i don't think that would
probably that as such isn't going to
work but something where i mean i've
always wanted a thing where we could use
placeholder as a pure function
i don't know how crazy that really is
because i don't think anybody
i think there's some user interface
things like if you generate a new
grid
yeah
the thing that looks like that
would be quite lovely
i mean of course slot
was partly picked
because that character
you know i've always thought we should
render slot as something which looks
like this with little tentacles on it
so okay maybe just
going up a level i mean what is the okay
again this is only one character away
from how you'd already write for pure
functions i think part of the reason
we're talking about this is because
there's some sense in which writing a
pure function like that is kind of like
quotes messy
but i don't know why
you know
i i don't know why exactly it looks
messy and then why this would be i mean
like it does look messy and this does
look cleaner but conceptually i don't
think okay they're
one way to make it look less messy is to
do something i wanted to do for like 30
years
which is to have maybe it already has
been done but that octothorpe as it's
officially called
um
has
i mean it
you know
how much like a box does it look
because it's still not looking like a
box it still looks like a very firmly
like an octo thorpe as opposed to just a
box with little you know knobs on it
is that why it's a hash because it wants
to look like an opening like a slot
yes i mean that was well it was yes that
was kind of the
uh
that was that momentary thought back you
know 35 years ago or something yes
i mean we didn't really have the idea
back then
of
sort of sort of deeply type setting you
know type setting in the in the ascii so
to speak which obviously developed later
but i mean that right there if if we
re-rendered this if we rendered this
character
so that it looked more like this
which is certainly within our you know
we're allowed to do that so to speak i
think that would help
well another thing is i mean i think one
of the things you've been doing recently
which has been good has been that we've
had asciization
or asciide forms of a lot of stuff like
the
function arrow right
yeah so i mean i you know i get i guess
we still have the ascii eyes to form
it's just hash but yeah it is right
that's exactly right but it just appears
it isn't even a different character it's
the same character it's just a rendering
question in the code font
although it's not quite because if you
have a string and in the middle of the
string you have one of these we don't
want it to render in some weird way fair
enough fair enough so so what this is
what that would be doing is potentially
using uh okay so this is a new degree of
freedom i agree with you the programming
ligatures mechanism would allow this to
potentially render as a different
character that is more slot-like or more
more box-like that seems like an
excellent idea
it also makes the possibility that
amazon with programming literature world
that an ampersand could render in some
different way as well
i mean honestly i think that the thing
that makes that feel messy is more the
dangling ampersand than is the hash
possibly
an smp yeah and that's of course also
what causes all the precedence issues
the dangling ampersand
well so that raises the question is
there could there be another form of
this
another way to write a pure function
as a
as a you know let's say a prefix
operator
well pre i mean would it be prefix or
would it be around the thing i mean
it starts to lose its value pretty much
well i mean if it's
if it's either prefix or match fix
it's still
i mean look clearly
you know
the story of this and this and so on
that's been a huge win no question
that's been a good idea
and
so this raises the question could there
be a prefix form of function
oh by the way hash
has basically been a good idea and the
you know losing it a nested pronouns
thing certainly happens to me a fair
amount you know as i write one function
with hash and then i want to put another
function around it and then i you know
i've either debroin indexing myself or
which i we can't do
or you know i'm actually giving names to
these things
in a perfect world
the
somehow
there would be some automatic
you know code assistance thing that
comes up and allows you to do the rename
you guys understand what i'm talking
about i'm saying if i say f of hash
and then i want to say ampersand
and then i want to say
g
of hash comma
and then i want to i want that hash
to decide that it refers into so if i
did g of x here i could put an f of
that an x
and then
let's see where i want to put this i
want to put this
i'm even confused where i'm putting it
i'm putting it even there
and now i want to say x
like that
and then i've reached inside the inner
ampersand
which i could not do
right i can only do that with a named
uh function argument
that makes sense
yep and the only way to do that if we
would use hash which i think is just
utterly flamingly obscure
is some kind of uh you know numbered
layers type thing which is just crazy
i mean the other thing is that if the if
the ampersand i i don't think i really
like the idea of having a prefix form of
ampersand but if the ampersand had been
set up at the beginning to be a prefix
form then it would be compatible with
the function arrow because at least you
wouldn't get into situations like this
where you have one thing at the
beginning and one thing at the end and
you don't know which one is the inside
and the outside
right i mean one of them would have to
come first
um i see but i don't think that doesn't
seem that bad for sand form is
equivalent to null function arrow body
well it's
i think they're the same pure function
like if you write null in the first
argument of a pure function it's i
didn't know that sure sure yeah but i
mean the the question is the so it's
like i'm talking there about this almost
like a prefix
it's not really a prefix operator i
guess
although i would never write the nail
arrow but sure
what are you saying i mean what what are
you claiming
so again so if i do this
parenthesize that and apply it to
something
i had no idea
i've seen it i think with the writing it
out with function i don't think i've
ever seen it with the arrow
wow well it certainly doesn't syntax
color correct the usefulness of this is
so that you can use the three argument
form of function
because you need something to put in the
first argument
you mean in the case where i say
function null
f of hash comma hold first or something
yeah
this way you can still use slots and
attributes
okay you know what this is not syntax
coloring correctly and that should be
reported
yep i had absolutely no idea that that
null thing i mean the fact you have to
parenthesize the arrow form is well i
guess it's not too bad because otherwise
it's completely obscure what's going on
i wonder whether there's an elided form
of the arrow a visually alighted form of
the arrow that could be a prefix
function
about lambda
that is the kind of standard thing
but i wonder whether we could make
something that kind of is like an
idealized lambda
well in haskell they use a backslash i
think because it kind of looks like the
top of a lambda
that is such a horrifying idea
um different languages i i could i could
look it up i could try and look it up i
feel like i've seen several different
languages done various sorts of things
like that you know slash backslash or
something stuff like that that kind of
looks a little bit like a lambda
yeah but we we have cooked the backslash
thing brother firmly as an escape
i believe
i believe i'm not certain i mean maybe
there's a
um
i mean we use backslash dot backslash
colon we use a whole bunch of backslash
type forms
um
but i mean i wonder
but honestly i feel like if we just have
another i mean it's one of these things
where like for example when someone is
learning
and people are already you know a little
bit confused about oh when should i
write function you know with with you
know the function name function or or
should i when should i use an ampersand
and you know you know explain oh well
it's just for convenience
but if we have then another thing that's
just as convenient as ampersand it's
kind of like
you know what by what process do you
decide which one to use yeah i'm not
sure
i have not had i mean like the at sign
and slash slash you could have said
exactly the same thing about that
but in fact people learn them as slang
basically they don't learn them
initially i mean that would not be the
correct thing to teach somebody the
first time they see a function you
should teach it with them to screw up
with square brackets
but as a slang when you're typing things
out it's very convenient
but then which is the slang of which if
you had both the some lambda thing and
you're the ampersand
the lander is the slang of the ampersand
but why i mean that's just for
historical reasons no i don't think so
because the ampersand is more general
wait i thought the the lambda we were
talking about is basically just a prefix
form of the ampersand
well maybe it is that
i think potentially lambda is both the
ampersand and the arrow like for all
um can have a subscript that's giving
what variables you're quantifying over
so i could picture like a lambda
subscript x
for named variables
right well so what would it look like
though if it was unnamed it would look
like this right
and if it was named
i mean that would be
something useful of add and double slash
is that they have different presence so
perhaps this could be used as a way of
actually mixing
the hashes
if the lambda for example has a lot more
precedence than the ampersand
why would that help in mixing hashes
because because then this thing has
bound and finished its its hash sign
binding when so you'd be able to write
something like lambda
f of hash
plus
ampersand
right
but wouldn't that be much clearer to
write with just multiple ampersands or
multiple lambdas because at least that
way you can tell which one's on the
inside and the outside
i think we should have a think about
whether there's a possibility of a
prefix form i like this idea that you
could subscript the variables i think
that's interesting
um
i think that there's you know one thing
that's changed in 30 years
is that
35 years ago
lambda was a known thing in mathematical
logic
and was pretty much unknown outside of
that
and we could argue that it has become
more widely known and we should consider
using that language you know that
natural language evolution and effect to
our advantage
so what we would do then is we would
have a stylized lambda-like thing that
might be some you know more like a for
all there exists which is a very um non
a very kind of uh
sort of linearly drawn straight line
drawn object
let's think about this some more okay so
we've got two action items we've got a
programming liquid sure around hash sign
to make it more placeholder like
and we've got the possibility of a i
mean i think we would want some kind of
uh
ascified form of the lambda that would
turn into some lambda object here
thoughts from people
i mean honestly things like the the
mapping the function arrow thing that is
really going to be mostly an expert
thing because it involves
knowing how you type it
etc etc etc
what about the presence of lambdas
because lambdas have
a strange way of combining if i remember
correctly
what do you mean a strange way of
combining
you mean a lambda in what in
mathematical logic
yes so there was this
am i confused
yes sorry i'm confused i think it it's
when you have terms and you you are not
using hashes and things like that
that you have to be careful with with
orders of things
yeah it's a huge mess i mean the fact
you know
old alonso church when he invented
lambda was completely unsure that it
would work and that's why he kind of
tried to translate to combinators where
he didn't have variables and things like
this
and i mean the fact is
that
you know in a sense hash sign
is a bit like using combinators except
that it doesn't well it does it doesn't
like using combinations it's only one
level
i mean combinators are the way that you
can you know you know everything is
going to work out okay in the end but
they are utterly obscure
utterly non-human understandable
i mean it'll be interesting to see as
the years go by whether you know now
that people more or less understand how
lambdas work you know will there come a
time when people actually understand how
combinators work
i'm skeptical
uh
okay okay so look coming back to our
original question should there be
operator forms for additional functions
i think
let's identify what the top two
next functions might be
and consider those and let's more
seriously consider this more general
solution
make sense people yeah
i think that makes sense to me
uh okay
i what is the case i i don't know this
but i should know it i mean after all
these years
if i do this
i have never done this like this that
this is so isn't it is it the case that
i can now say okay so i take that and i
say x
oh how nice
if you just evaluate it even you know
the the output form will show it with an
ampersand
okay but the main point here is that if
i say something like um
uh you know color function arrow
function blah blah blah
i don't have to deal with all this crazy
i mean yeah although it technically it
is fewer characters to do in ampersand
in parentheses
i never told me personally when i'm
using parentheses i would rather rewrite
the code to have brackets
so which i i do parentheses ampersand
i'd probably use function in this case
for that right
i have the same instinct but i don't
know why because it's kind of like i
mean it's just as readable i think and
it's and it's just as i mean it might
even be more readable because it's a
different type of bracket which makes it
more clear where it ends
and you know but i agree that it looks
kind of uglier in some way
right
well i think it's perhaps it's because
all right so we've got this and we've
got this
i think part of the problem here is that
there's just an awful lot of you know
just
obscure punctuational characters
involved
[Music]
also the outer parens are like
a like why do we need this
it's not obvious why the i think that's
one of the issues is it's not obvious
why they're needed
because yeah
i mean our friends always sort of feel
like a failure of precedence
yes
but these outer parens
you know if i'm writing
x plus 1 times x plus 2 or something
times 2 plus x those parens don't bother
me you know what it is it's parens that
have no
yes it's okay okay parens like this
don't bother me
the problem here is that we're so used
to seeing arrow without a parenthesis
thing on the right hand side that it
just seems just weird that there are
outer parens hanging out there
another point is just that if you don't
know what you're doing you might forget
the prince
well yes
perhaps it's also
parentheses that are outside mathematics
so they feel more natural in mathematics
well that's true
yeah
yeah
right like when i write something like
if you're writing something with uh
you know nested maps you know and
usually the precedence is correct but
sometimes you need parentheses and that
also feels kind of ugly
well i mean okay so the alternative here
would be
a um
hmm
that's going to be weird too
well we should try this
i had never even thought of this
this seems
yeah i mean of these forms
this is definitely obscure
and i wonder given that we're doing all
these programming legit show things i
wonder what would happen
if in this form
there's nothing that tells us that
visually those brands have to look the
same as all other parents
i don't know that really helps but
that didn't even work
i mean historically what what was the
reasoning behind the ampersand
as a character yeah i mean is it trying
to look like a lambda or something no i
i don't think so it was
it was an escape from the way this
worked in snp
which is what we're going back to
um
smp
defaulted to
everything would be applied as a head
let's see how did this work
snp had this mechanism where
let's see smp did not have the idea of
composite heads in the same way that we
have now
and it had to have this thing that
called a mark
which was just a disastrous object
which was a thing that said
when you apply this
do the equivalent of two ampersand
rather than if you said f
as the function to apply it will happily
wrap f around things
but it didn't have a good way to say
actually think of this as
the
the pure 2
not a 2 that will be wrapped around
things
and so it had this notion of a mark
to deal with that
and that was so horrifying
let's actually look at what it did um
hold on one second
let me just see since we are returning
to so many of the things that um
uh let's see
um
okay
okay there's the smp precedence table
but that was another interesting idea
pre-simplification that was a
uh evaluate this that was that was the
equivalent of evaluate but done in the
in the parser
which i think in modern times
basically happens by people selecting
something and typing command
you know return
i don't think that has a real place in
modern times
um
some of these were just frigging
disastrous
uh i think how set has a colon equals is
a single equals that seems like kind of
a
another bad idea it was a bad idea
um
as was i mean you know quite a few of
these things like
uh
that was outer
oh yeah that was interesting that was
that was the equivalent of percent
x
um but coming back down here to to mark
see where mark shows up here
oh don't tell me that the only place it
shows oh no
it might only be written with a
back
back tick which which your ocr is not
gonna get
yes i know
oh look at this this is funny this is um
because in those days ascii was a was
not the only uh character encoding
ebcdic was also alive and well
um
okay hold on let me just find this
ah
ah let's see
where would it be um
i would imagine this would be in a
section
there are some things here chameleonic
expressions is another one of these
super bizarre ideas
that was for dealing with um
that was the equivalent of module
variables where you could have a single
variable that every time it was
mentioned would change its name
where would this be
um
maybe 2.7 templates thing that might be
where it is
i don't remember what a template is
oh come on
why isn't this
help
oh there's pre and post
living already
uh
monitor escapes
i think we've finally discontinued these
and they're not for lizards either
okay two points basically it sounds like
basically just that the back tick was
was basically he did the ampersand
and it was a prefix
but the backtick was the inverse of an
ampersand that is the backtick
caused things to let me just look
np was the equivalent of sequence
why is this not scrolling properly it's
crazy
um
oh for goodness sake come on
isn't this like a several hundred page
document that you're scrolling through
well yes are you trying to find the page
for mark i'm trying to find the page for
mark
um
templates
here we go here we go here we go here we
go
is an expression specifying action be
taken on a set of expressions
oh
gosh
okay the problem this had was that's
right that was the issue this did not
distinguish between functions and
pattern variables
so dollar x was both
a
see look at this this is look at this
thing here
i don't even know what order it was
taking the men
how did this possibly work
this is an apply
okay it was like x the equivalent of
hash one
dollar i assume so but i assume it was
in canonical order but that seems just
completely crazy
the association of si with di is
determined first of them by sorting the
di into canonical order
oh so you could use abc if you wanted to
and it would just sort them that's
completely insane
well this is a pronoun this is solving
this is a version of the pronoun problem
that is really weird
here okay so there's one unfilled
slot
which gets left over
that's the equivalent of of hash
okay let's just see how mark shows up
okay so mark
okay so the the unification here is
between pattern variables and slots
which appears to me to be simply a bad
idea
although as we look at two-way rules
it's starting to rear its head again
um okay so this was the thing that was
not figured out in smp
was the notion of composite heads
because that was what s p did for a
composite head
it basically didn't like it
um oh and that was another incredibly
bad idea that was a list
as a head
being applied to
a number is equivalent to part
sorry interrupt here i'm gonna have to
step out for a minute
okay we need to wrap fairly soon here
but
but
okay so most of what's here is just bad
ideas
right so in this case
i had forgotten the sorting of i've
forgotten the unification of pattern
variables and slots
unfortunately this multi-replace
function needs to have something i mean
and
when we were talking about uh supplied
we were talking about something again
where we have some need to unify
patterns and slots
if i'm not mistaken right because
supplied
has in it
you know hash index type variables
as well as having um
as well as the possible the the most
recent thing we discussed was having
lots of new symbols that are like dollar
dollar index and dollar dollar position
yeah that's right that's right things
like that good idea
yeah that's a good idea would just then
be the non-lexically scanned form
right you list the
yeah i forgot the
symbols that you want all right well
there's probably nothing we can learn
from this this is um
although it is amusing this this
canonical ordering of of pattern of slot
names is amusing
if probably a bad idea
okay
um
well let's see if we can dispatch one
more thing here so i think we've got a
plan for how at least what to explore
here
so these are two uh proposed new
functions that are taking
the tops of trees
uh in two different ways the ancestor
tree takes a list of positions
and treetop just takes a level
so the
thing
i'm wanting to discuss here is just
approving do we approve both of these
functions before no we haven't um
did we did we discussed the idea that
would be two different functions for
this
no we haven't gotten uh
this is a follow-up on our previous
discussion where we proposed having
something like treetop
okay you believe there's a need to have
also a thing called ancestor tree yes
because so for treetop you want to be
able to just say like treetop comma two
and have the top two levels i search the
same
the the treetop
so one thing that i want to make sure of
is
you are very big on labeled trees
but a lot of the uses that i've had are
big trees without labels
but without visible labels
um
but what you're saying is
this is the ancestor tree why can't i
say the ancestry of
i see there's no guarantee that the
payload i have to refer to it by
position in the tree
yeah so this is in the tree extract tree
insert tree delete family
so one thing one question is the name
should it be ancestor tree or should it
be tree
something
i understand
and tree top which is a bit of a
whimsical name
just takes the tree down to a certain
level
yep
well i agree these are both useful
functions
now what is the what is the downward
looking ancestor tree if i want e and i
want every every piece of the tree
hanging below e what do i do
that's tree extract
i mean what about tree above
so the other ones are like tree and then
some action like tree extract tree
insert tree delete
is tree extract actually the right name
if it was tree above and tree below
would that actually be better naming
so extract works like extract does in
that you can give it a single position
and you get
a single tree or a single expression or
you can give it a list and then you get
a list of trees or a list of expressions
first of all what were you saying
the same thing it's like extract
yeah
okay but though what will be the analog
of i mean this is sort of like what is
the analog of this of the the being
above
this would be like if in delete you
could say something like
delete um
you know to come all
like you're trying to delete everything
below
certain positions
what would it look like though because
because in a tree you can just
quarterize the end by putting a null
uh null collection of subtrees but an
expression it's less obvious how you
cauterize the end other than by having a
guess of function with no arguments
um
okay so it would be exactly that like if
you had f of one two three
and you just wanted
level zero you'd get just f open close
okay the tree of ancestors of a list of
sub-trees
so what is that that's some kind of
spanning
yeah so you keep the positions that you
specify and
their ancestors
so that you get something that's
connected ultimately to the root and you
exclude everything else
so that's everything on other branches
and everything below those positions
everything on other branches
hold on so if you've got all three of
these
this means
everything you need to kind of rig to
hang those pieces will be there yep
a suggestion from michael on the
livestream tree take
why is that right
tree take was
uh one of your suggestions actually for
treetop
like you could say tree take well i
think that makes some sense and take it
the difference with take is that take is
the take specs are more flexible
for one and that's like taking a number
of elements of a list
and this is
like
truncating the levels
or for ancestor trees
position specs
see it is a little bit odd that we can
do this for a tree but we can't do it
for an expression which is after all a
tree that the treetop operation i think
it's a sensible operation on expressions
it's very similar to shallow
yes
and essentially what one would do is to
say i mean the question is what do you
cauterize with
because you are cauterizing somehow
you've got you've got dangling ends
you've got to fill something in for
those i don't fill in anything for them
so i know you don't know true expression
it's a little bit more weird because you
end up with zero argument functions
exactly
well so
i guess the problem is that if you apply
this operation to an expression you'll
get some other expression unless your
thing is just a totally inner expression
it could go bonkers yeah
and but if you give it a quarterization
cork so to speak
then
to put in those
sort of dangling ends
what you really need is to wrap the
whole thing and like hold
maybe
i'm not sure how useful that is but i
mean i think
i think a pretty common thing is it is
fairly inert it's a bunch of lists but
you just want to see the top layers
and you can do that visually by using
shallow
but there's no good way to do that
you know
really what this is is the shallow
equivalent of take
is for a structure that is a sequential
array-like structure
and shallow
is at least visually for a thing that
has hierarchical structure
so the question is what
um
i think we're running out of time here
we got to pick this up next time
uh
okay
yes i mean this these are basically just
naming questions i think at this point i
think we i think we're agreeing on the
functionality here
um
fine
okay all right see you guys soon